okay so it's time to dip our toes back
into the music scene
and see what songs the kids are
listening to today the one
that was brought to my attention by
someone in the comment section
uh it's it's a new joint it's some real
dope from my homie polo g
i've been a big fan of polo g for a long
time as everyone knows polo g
yeah real name taurus chirmani bartlett
born january 6 1999 he's an american
rapper singer songwriter
and record executive in 2018 he rose to
prominence with the singles finer things
and pop out
uh in 2021 he released the song rap star
which debuted at number one
on the hot 100. the song became his
first number one hit on the hot 100 and
his first solo
top 10 single i know all this stuff top
my head i'm just there's just
information i know
as a fan anyway rap star is the song
and it's been number one on youtube for
you know weeks now has like 50 million
views
big deal big hit let's uh let's check it
out
[Music]
okay quick quick thing here what what
kind of dealership
transaction is this the dude shows up
with a duffel bag
full of cash at the dealership and then
the guy literally has a silver platter
with all the keys for his cars ready is
this how it works for rappers is this
what it means to be a rapper that that's
how it works when you go to car
dealership
i suggest you get started on the
paperwork
i bought a pickup truck a couple months
ago and i had i was there for hours i
was doing paperwork
going through the warranty plans they
never talked about warranties
financing all that
i guess i should have just walked in
with a bag of cash thrown it on the
table and said hey i'm taking that car
right there
peace out and then peeled out in the car
of course if i had done that then the
person at the dealership would have been
like uh sir you gave me 87
and 12 cents that's not enough to buy a
car anyway but apology has uh has
more money to throw around than i do you
know admittedly and that's fine and he's
he's buying rides for all his homies
which is great very sweet of him
um if i was a homie waiting in line to
get my car
i might stop polo g and say
alyssa polo g look i know beggars can't
be choosers but can i get another color
besides white
i don't want to spend every other day
for the next seven years at a car wash
if you don't mind i'd be a little
ungrateful though i guess all right
let's uh let's keep
listening i ain't joking do it sound
like i'm kidding i've been making like 2
000 a minute
so okay i got to stop it already i i
mean it does
kind of sound like you're kidding 2 000
a minute
you've been making dollars a minute is
what you tell us polo g
that's someone do the math on that
i need a calculator well that's like
what that's uh so it's a 2 000 a minute
120 grand an hour
24 hours in a day someone help me out
with the math
uh so that's like what like 2.8 million
a day right
let's call it three million maybe polo
g's been a little bit modest
so we're talking this guy is making over
a
billion dollars a year who is
this jeff is this what jeff bezos looks
like
not what i expected to be honest
not to stereotype okay don't take that
the wrong way so high up through the
clouds i was swimming
i'm probably gonna drown when i'm in it
i bet she gonna get loud when i'm in it
and we might have a child she can't get
near me
only [ __ ] i'll give a conversation to a
siri my parents are married
yes i'm winning clearly i'm the chosen
one see my potential so they fear me
lately i've been praying god i wonder
can you hear me thinking about the
old me i swear i miss you dearly stay
down till you come up i've been sticking
to that theory
every day about it i'm exhausted and i'm
weary make sure i'm smiling okay
let's check out the lyrics here um he
says
i won't love a hoe after we have sexual
relations
she can't get near me only [ __ ] i give
a conversation to
is siri my pants amiri yes i'm winning
clearly
i'm the chosen one see my potential so
they fear me
lately i've been praying god i wonder
can you hear me thinking about the old
me i swear i miss you dearly
stay down till you come up i've been
sticking to that theory every day of
battle
i'm exhausted and i'm weary now this is
great i love how he goes he goes from
bragging about all his hoes
and bragging about the brand name of his
pants he's proud of his pants
and then in the next line he's crying
out to god in agony i too am
extraordinarily humble
that's quite an emotional rollercoaster
that he has us on
every day is a battle it's a struggle in
my ten thousand dollar pants on my
private jet
after i just bought 10 bmws for no
reason i'm str god
why hast thou forsaken me
all right let's
[Music]
all but that [ __ ] continue me severely
i've been getting hot i have behind my
insecurities taking different pills but
i know it ain't gonna
cop the bmw new deposit i picked up
another bag like [ __ ] it i'm a cow while
i'm in it
i had planes flying crowds screaming
money counting shane's clanking [ __ ]
like that's the side
sound when you win i ain't joking do it
sound like i'm kidding i've been making
like 2
000 a minute so high up through the
clouds i was swimming
i'm probably gonna drown when i'm
[Music]
okay let's uh let's review for here for
a moment
what has happened so far here he is in
this part of the song
after he's bragged about his pants and
his hoes and his cars and money and
jewelry
is now holding a small child his own i
mean he's holding his own child
presumably
while he raps the following i ain't
joking do it sound like i'm kidding i've
been making like 2 000 a minute
so high up through the clouds i was
swimming i'm probably gonna drown when
i'm in it
i bet she's gonna get loud when i'm in
it and we might have a child when i'm
finished
they say i'm poc rebirth never put out a
weak first
homicides when we lurk i'ma step till my
feet hurt
okay now in fairness the kid he wasn't
there for the last two lines
so that's good you know that's that is
responsible parenting
so you know he said to his kid okay uh
son daddy has to brag about killing
people now so you're gonna have to leave
the room for this part
but he was holding the kid while he said
i bet she'd gone get loud while i'm in
it
and we might have a child when i'm
finished is this his version
of the birds and the beast talk boys
have a penis
girls have a vagina i appreciate he's
trying to include his son in his job you
know like a take your child to work day
sort of thing
take your child to the rap video set but
maybe bring him in for a song that isn't
about you know having sex with hoes and
killing your enemies
i realize that might eliminate every
song in polo g's catalog
but uh either way just a little
parenting
far be it for me to dole out advice but
there it is when putting them streets
first
yt's turn burgundy t-shirts looking for
some real he's stuck in the deep surface
anxiety killing me i just want to leave
when they ask if i'm okay
[Music]
i mean please don't talk i don't been
okay i think we get the idea uh so he
says anxiety killing me
i just want to leave earth when they ask
if i'm okay i did just make everything
seem worse
this is like a 14 year old girl's diary
entry
trying to explain your feelings sounds
like something you rehearsed
stab me in my back with a clean smirk
looking so deep into your eyes i can
read your thoughts
so shut the f i mean please don't talk
i done been through too much i don't
need another loss
put that on every war scar for every
battle i fought you know what in all
seriousness he
he does i'll say this he does a pretty
good job of rhyming here
it's like poetry so if they rhyme uh and
even rhyming in multiple syllables so
credit words do
and i guess the message i'm getting here
from the song is that listen
you know gangsters have feelings too i
guess
which is also the plot of the sopranos
incidentally you know what i wet my ass
with your feelings
thanks thanks a lot the point is yes you
know they they have the women
yes they have the money yes they have
the private jet yes they're busting cabs
in various asses and so forth
but at the end of the day they just want
to feel
loved and that
well that's a message i'm not sure how
relatable it is
or worthwhile but it is a message
you know and so that's an improvement
over many other rap songs which don't
seem to
be saying really anything at all so by
default
i'm actually going to give this one two
thumbs up